trois nouveaux bus avec des sièges bleus
pour les places traditionnelles rouge
pour celles réservées aux personnes
prioritaires des lampes à led et même
des ports usb ile-de-france mobilité et
la ratp présenter les véhicules vendredi
29 mars
voilà donc voilà la prise la prise de
charge donc là vous branchez le bus
comme comme une voiture plus que leur
design extérieur la nouveauté vient
surtout de ce qu'ils ont sous le capot
des batteries les bus du constructeur
français sont 100% électrique
nous rentrons aujourd'hui dans une
nouvelle ère de transition énergétique
et de véhicules propres et c'est là pour
nous l'occasion de rentrer dans cette
nouvelle ère aussi d'apprendre ces
matériels roulants qui sont nouveaux une
nouvelle technologie et d'en profiter
pour que nos conducteurs saad s'adapte à
cette nouvelle de technologie
aujourd'hui on a des véhicules tri qui
arrive on va avoir une expérimentation
sur des bus à hydrogène dans quelques
mois
et donc c'est important parce que on
peut pas continuer à une de france a
tourné avec des véhicules diesel twitter
tout à 250 km d'autonomie pour des bus
qui circulent en moyenne entre 180 et
220 km par jour
ils seront rechargées au dépôt chaque
soir les chauffeurs apprennent dès à
présent à pratiquer une conduite
économique récupérer l'énergie ont
rechargé les batteries vers vous avez
une conduite économique
orange et rouge
vous tirez sur le gâteau ces trois bus
sont les premiers du réseau ile de
france à être mises en circulation de 12
mètres de long ils peuvent accueillir 85
voyageurs c'est un honneur pour 5
octobre que la région donc à financer
l'intégralité de ses bus voilà les
mettre à disposition au premier de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la région ile
de france a pour ambition d'équiper 100
% du territoire en véhicules propres
d'ici 2030